ich gebe jetzt hier einfach mal zeit 50
1 also ein 50 mal so groß wie normal
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft heute am dienstag das heißt
ich will zeigen nicht mal vor jeder form
ein waldbrand schweiz eigentlich nicht
mal vor jeder folge sagen aber heute
kommt wieder das geheimnisvolle
geräusche das heißt irgendwann in diesem
video werde ich ein geheimnisvolles
geräusch machen und ihr könnt dann in
den kommentaren erraten welches geholt
werden eventuelle der nächsten folge
erwähnt und ich würde sagen empfangen
direkt an
mit dem ersten effekt erst effekt wurde
mir nämlich zugesendet von pascal und
zwar spawn ich jetzt erst mal einen wolf
den mache ich erstmal dass er mich liebt
dokument liegt mir einfach direkt schon
und jetzt nämlich eine lite und jetzt
kann man den wolf er somit sich mit
zäher und so dass damit damit geht und
man kann auch fliegen wenn man im game
und 1 ist natürlich kann man da fliegen
und dann fliegt der wolf einer natürlich
auch hinterher
allerdings wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
mal diese leine wegschmeißen würde würde
ja eigentlich die leine quasi
runterfallen und mit der leine dann auch
der wolf allerdings ich mache jetzt mal
deine weg ihr seht die liegt da unten
und ich kann ihnen wolf immer noch mit
mir rum zählen
ich geh jetzt mal wieder nach unten ich
hoffe der steht jetzt nicht so rund 0 2
noch mal kurz um zu demonstrieren
ich kann in wolke mit hochziehen und da
kann ich einfach die leine wegschmeißen
und der wolf bleibt quasi alleine ich
hoffe der star der steht jetzt nicht und
ich kann jetzt einfach beispielsweise
hier mit dem weiteren laufen also wenn
ich die leine wegschmeißen macht das
ganze eigentlich gar keinen sinn weil
der hund immer noch an einer leine ist
und das perfekt machen und jetzt konfekt
maz kommen wir zum zweiten sektor zwar
wurde dieser effekt mir zugesagt von
paul und zwar meint paul du hast ja hier
so einen dorfbewohner und der ist ja
ganz schön und gut allerdings wenn ich
einen blitz auf diesen dorfbewohner
drauf schleudere dann verwandelt er sich
in eine hexe blitz können wir erzeugen
die märz-zahlen lightning vollmacht
nicht ruhig mal eltern und ihr seht
schon der dort wohl da wird einfach zur
sonne hexe also ein blitz kann da schon
eine menge verändern
ich glaube dorfbewohner werden ja auch
zu diesem dorf zombies werden die vom
zombie in die attacke attackiert werden
oder so das hat auch eine gewisse chance
und das ist auf jeden fall relativ cool
das heißt wenn ganz viele dorfbewohner
haben und dann gewitter ist ammann hat
euch nicht wenn einem eine hexe baisweil
da wo dieser dorfbewohner einfach wohl
von einem blitz getroffen
ich befinde mich hier gerade an der welt
border ihr könnt ganz normal mit diesem
befehl irgendwie zu euch in der nähe
world order run gelangen sporting wieder
vorn oder so und du hast einfach mehrere
stempel man nie wie geil ist das denn
nicht telepathie mich irgendwohin und
das einfach so ein meeres tempel im
wasser ok neues aber was ich eigentlich
sagen wollte ist perfekt denn wir von
daniel taylor johnny lloyd in minecraft
zu gewinnen wurde und zwar kann man mit
hilfe von ender perlen außerhalb von der
wolke oder kommen wenn ich im creative
in kann natürlich kein ende verschmelzen
das heißt wir gehen in den gamern 0 und
ich weiß jetzt einfach mal so eine ende
hin und bin jetzt außerhalb von der
world oder das einzige was passiert ist
dass man dabei ein bisschen neben
verliert das sehen wir jetzt da verliere
ich ein bisschen leben weil ich hier rum
lauf und ist so weiter ich mich jeder
von verlaufe von der world water desto
mehr leben verliert allerdings kann ich
hier vorne ruhig schon ein bisschen
schön und weil ihr nicht so viel leben
und nur dieses leben was ich natürlich
diese endete dadurch verliere und quasi
mit einer perle
kann ich aus als von ihr von der world
border mich bewegen und es ist auf jeden
fall richtig cool wenn man mal schauen
möchte wie es hinter der grenze aus und
ich würde sagen wir bleiben direkt hier
für den vierten effekt und zwar habe ich
euch ja schon einmal gezeigt dass wenn
ich mit einem bogen unter wasser schieße
dass diese pfeile gebremst werden ich
versuche ich das jetzt mal hier so ein
bisschen zu zeigen mit dieser stelle die
ich hier oben ein bisschen habe man den
fall beobachtet ihr seht schon da geht
nach unten
das funktioniert aber nicht nur mit
einem bogen sondern das funktioniert
auch mit einem schneeball wenn ihr mir
jetzt beispielsweise mal seht dieser
schnee bei dir direkt nach unten wenn
ich damals irgendwie so ein schneeball
hinwerfe ob nicht jeder fall direkt nach
unten
und wenn ich ihn hier hinweg würde würde
eigentlich noch zur wand gehen aber hier
geht er direkt nach unten und das
gleiche funktioniert auch mit einer
ender perle wo wir gerade bei ender
perlen sind so und sie geht einfach
direkt nach unten und ich habe nur noch
ein herz ich möchte das nicht noch mal
machen heute nur noch ein herz aber die
keinen bock abzusterben ach komm mal
direkt nochmal so da er hinschmeißen
jedenfalls seht ihr glaube ich schon
dass relativ viele gegenstände gebremst
werde im wasser also alles was sie in
wie wegschmeißen könnte et cetera
und das war nicht nur der bogen der das
was ich in den letzten folgen gesagt hat
sondern auch schneebälle und ender
perlen und was ich sonst alles geht
alles im wasser gebremst und das perfekt
auf ihren jetzt kompakt 05.05 kommt aus
dem minecraft forum und zwar ist das ein
fact über einen herbst wahrscheinlich
schon auf dem feld gesehen da war ein
riesiger slum abgebildet und zwar kann
man mit diesem buch ich bin einfach
zweimal ein oder moment und zwar kann
man mit diesem befehl einen größeren
spawn als die normal also das hier ist
jetzt erledigt ist
ich bin einfach direkt tot und da sind
wir auch schon bei einem geheimnisvollen
geräusch angekommen und zwar wohl das
letzte ganz ohne geräusche raten von
pascal leidenberger er meint das
geräusch einer hilft lama die duh
zugemacht hat also in einem akten hefter
hashtag vollidiot herstellt wird jetzt
also das war auf jeden fall richtig dass
am sehr wenige erraten doch relativ
schwer ich muss noch sagen es kam ein
richtig cooler kommentar an von mutter
geschrieben
auf jeden fall richtig kranker kommentar
und ich würde erstmal sagen jetzt kommt
das geheimnisvolle geräusch für diesen
tag das war das geheimnisvolle geräusche
wenn ihr erraten könnt dann schreibe es
in die kommentare ich denke es wird
diesmal richtig richtig schwer
ich habe mich als man den gamern 1
gepackt und zwar so sind normale slams
normal großes lines dann ist zeigten
also der ist schon mal viel viel größer
und ihr wollt es natürlich alle wissen
es wird allerdings total ruckeln
ich gebe jetzt hier einfach mal seit 50
jahren also ein 50 mal so groß sein wie
normal und den schauen wir uns einfach
mal an und zwar sieht er dann so aus wir
können das ganze auch eventuell mal auf
100 erhöhen ich weiß jetzt bei minecraft
an nicht leid abschnitt aber wir machen
so einfach mal so und hier haben wir
jetzt ein slime mit der größe 100 pesos
etwa der riesiges land je gesehen habe
und er hilft doch einfach einmal hilft
ist ein paar tausend blöcke weiter so
guckt euch das mal an und er kann hier
eigentlich kein krieg ok es einfach
schon aus der welt gepackt glaube ich
besser und artikel richtig krank aus die
haben ja irgendwie seite als es ruckelt
es mädchen die haben wir seit der 1.8
sogar ein bisschen alter verstehen sogar
unseren bisschen gehirn und das sieht er
so richtig eklig roadie drin aus und war
abartig egal das war noch jeden fall die
minecraft das geheimnisvolle geräusche
kamen ja vorhin wenn ihr es erraten hab
dann schreib deine kommentare habe ich
auch schon gesagt und die sind einfach
jetzt alle weg mein pc richtig wegen den
slums hallo wo ist denn überhaupt denn
jetzt helfe abgehauen
naja ist ja egal
das war's mit der heutigen folge da ist
auch noch ein dorf wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann zeigt es mir bitte mit einer
bewertung weil in letzter zeit alle mama
in diese scheiße diesem ein kräftiges
folgen aber die meisten von euch feiern
deswegen effekt könnt ihr mir per mail
an konkreter gmail.com sendezeit mit
einer bewertung hält euch gefallen hat
zeigt die freundin die folge oma oder
opa nennt sie auch interessiert und dann
sehen wir uns in der nächsten episode am
freitag ohne ganz tolles golf wieder